[Applaudissements]
il bat jean michel maire
bonsoir toits d'anciens l'instant sera
le conseil de classe d'isabelle morini
bosc et ça va saigner un ouais t'as
rez-de-chaussée oui ben ali même si ce
week-end par exemple à l'entente fond
quel panard le foot ce que tu as fait
celui qui a la réponse africaine boulot
boulot alors dans la musique moi je ne
fais quoi ce week-end à moi j'ai baisé
en fait non mon boulot les gars alors
vous êtes malade ou quoi excusez vous
donne-t-il et emmène moi je reste plus
ou moins j'étais avec mon excuse moi
c'est maintenant que vous me le dites
oui mais quand tu dis que c'est le
boulot boulot ça ça veut dire quoi c'est
quoi ton pour l'heure elle est l'amie la
musique me c'est sur du classique g1
publié au cinquième de beethoven la
cinquième de beethoven le cinquième
épisode de béton de ses chiens c'est
vrai quoi vous faire oui nous tentons
d'antan qui a très bien fait puisque moi
c'est une question de rythme moi il faut
choisir le thème la musique militaire
j'aime pas commencé lentement accélérée
c'est des conneries c'est la perte de
temps mon fou que ça soit tout de suite
à fond à dire avec 130 et attirer les
pme et les filles adorent j'adore la
musique classique revient très fort ah
oui il parait brasserie de la musique
classique japonais de chez le dentiste
bateau l'identié succès il vous met de
la musique classique c'est toujours
l'impression qu'on va chez une de rite
landes
mais en fait c'est pendant qu'on
m'arrache thierry moreau